welcome to this video playing FM de
Becque from Slovakia FM the name yeah
yeah lots of information in there but
not the name ok so I'm going to play
this slightly offbeat Lyonya could pry
chick variation key regions posts into
something that probably longs to the to
the souls in variation k is played with
short castling could we get a five yeah
this is some very classical way to play
it try to open up the long diagonal here
from a not so long but very dangerous a
to f7 diagonal hmm Jaffa GUI five okay
let's do that gives up some control over
d5 but I hope for be 5a five and and
stuff like that it seems that she wants
to play Bishop h4
a five and before anyway maybe
hmm Bishop g5 played this very quickly
don't think that this should be so bad
for me I do need to take immediately
yeah I have just really taking my bed
Bishop on his heaven okay now while he's
setting up the pin but this really
shouldn't be any big problem him d 6 is
weak but I don't have cause every move
get played instantly here that's so easy
everything I don't know
Roxy one how do i how do I play that
maybe check tick and rook before taking
a 44 he has some weaknesses as well be
four and a forearm and he's got the
slightly worse kings okay now his back
rank is also week I a tricky position I
don't I don't really know what he what
you should do now rook c8 is a movie I'd
gives a check but it it exposes the back
rank is completely ignoring everything
here or not okay should I just take you
for he's got queen hey Don what is the
big ideas what this would threaten made
of course
can also go look default trying to
thread a new book the one made
hmm
don't know what is he going to do now
aged three I could give the check King
edge 294 check but he's got King g3 and
after that I don't really have a decent
move and I g4 may be immediately here
naija form or is this just a shocker
move that does not really help take so
q1 is made can you do with this parano I
don't know I notice I don't see it so
let's try I already said after Luke c8
that the background is weak so time I am
so we just found this one check
can you give this check here it's not so
clear what is a cold lashing though
check
check
check fatigue on h4 is he playing Quincy
8 and meet me that would be sick I have
96 though everything else fails covering
a jade how do i get to the king here
I don't see it unbelievable
check
Jack an unbelievable game jack jack okay
we went on time I only have one second
left leg 5 feds aren't I how idiotic was
that yeah I mean his playing is like a
suicide mission bending the back ring
and everything and this was very lucky
that he had g3 but he's still alive and
now okay this is just suicide of course
96 and nope later I just play a trial of
course why didn't I play h5 is not very
difficult age 5 and he resigns okay
simply has no movie can take a clan we
kept shined I'm threatening this with a
win i played this panicking yeah and
after that he said he's still in the
game Jack Jack Jack me okay he did
didn't matter Black is better at the end
again but didn't really didn't really
matter much Jack yeah I was very
surprised some moves my takes his
sadness one of them and check but I came
here before not quite sure I mean this
is some probably better for wide with da
porn I was just surprised so quickly
played it be three because I need talent
and play ya can't see a Desai think very
surprising played of course gladly this
rook said it does not help him in any
way and it just exposes the back rank
and he never ever saw any old heads I
just stumbled into g3 and this is this
is just a draw still quite remarkably
check
check ken played can play it to g1 and
then I need to give this perpetual check
check check check yeah this as mentioned
is just as are just suicide but there
are not a play age 5 is of course sir
just plain idiotic i also have Queen f6
next to continue okay thanks for
watching